it's your boy psychobabble here playing
hunter / hunted okay and it's Donald
Trump you can't really see his mask but
I can tell you he's very good-looking
and its strong right here can I steal
the [ __ ] action he is about one in here
that'd be cool aviator cap which be
badass okay let's get the [ __ ] out of
here there's all this shows you need all
this racers
he'll [ __ ] is this cabin eating carrot a
station God can oh yeah why would they
write that answer I can't okay let's
tear this [ __ ] else let's def house
Oh what the [ __ ] all right and exile
level up real quick okay can I can't
hurt leftist let's do this yes yes yes
yes yes yes yeah okay okay
let's see here I'll paint it this way
I can fly if they were here this Boston
campus Boston University so sad and
since then I'm a [ __ ] scream okay see
how can I get around this [ __ ]
ah the [ __ ]
I get what I go to turn the radio to
frequency
alright let's say let's say
this place is a [ __ ] chump cit brands
ok course your signal found let's tennis
9.48 no wrong way Wow ok good cat get
like 10 that's weird I was ur be here
later now the radio signal is getting
louder
I just show up at kellis passionate [ __ ]
I'm losing it Rory's 41 no not that way
poor daddy I can't to hear again
yeah turn turn if I can get in here
they're [ __ ] sneak away in here I
guess you had a [ __ ] around and they
got this guy's
Jesus what the [ __ ] is going on over
there if one's exclaiming 67 doing well
doing well fix it a seven-day cut got
got 70 watt cut get gonna sleep here 73
74 shut-eye losing it all right yeah
[ __ ] sex [ __ ] it's over here 70 69 what
the [ __ ]
okay Oh what the [ __ ] are all these dogs
down here 81 ok 8486 [ __ ] 85 90 ok rock
right there anything
86 91 92 the [ __ ] is going on here the
[ __ ] that I gotta go you take this
building okay it's just I got the scores
and get out of here you know playing
games all day John the second idea
oh ok
the coursers on the second floor kill on
sight send reinforcements oh and they
know that cats guy hello I Kelly you're
a pack thank you can't sneak from strong
forever okay that's like this [ __ ]
right here God God he's an owl good
thing that's classes
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna die
shut okay good thing I say like just
there whoa look at him he's a little
pool new tactic strong forever Destler
patch and out that I came out their
flight now is that we think this hey who
are these guys this is the Brotherhood
of Steel oh hello baybay hello god yes
hello I'd up ahead well thank ya huh
barricades stairwells and hallways if
you haven't already so there's a guy
here yeah he's right here I got ya
you're mostly pay me to put those down
you know
the [ __ ] is going on over no better
saying yeah well these losers are
fighting I'm gonna be hacking like a
good guy [ __ ] hey [ __ ] for
anything is than I am this is a [ __ ]
missile ok we're gonna have to pick a
run for it that
like this [ __ ] up Oh chef chef okay
okay i guess the guys from work enhance
you know huh God got over huh he's got
cool glasses hair
[ __ ] babe mmm okay
love can take it cut there's ass in here
okay
huh he's like oh [ __ ] he's got his
[ __ ] sucked out in fact let me get my
[ __ ] good outfit on okay there's a
couple things I name okay oh [ __ ]
apparel I gotta put on my dog collar I
cook that where is it worth it so trip
armor it's a sunglasses yes yes
strong forever
and their fight neuqua sharp as I got
your not know if they're winning but the
chime another tournament there we go oh
ok [ __ ] am I going gut gut I can't take
this guy go put this guy not shine here
good
when I find that kosher I'm gonna take
out my pistol my shotty and just go
right for him that bowling pin it [ __ ]
here yeah that's super sure out yeah
badass
bad ass wait no I went this way okay
gotta go all the way down there just
getting insane low oh great up strong
survive that that was a nasty trick I
just did
perfect car these people think I think
they gotta be the brother right
don't know what the [ __ ] that was but I
got it good Jesus picnics so much [ __ ]
quick saving man chest looks I gotta go
combat shotgun now
where is that hacking this is beyond me
step out light here have it up so that
noise
I
did he just kill him are you going to
cooperate
are you here for the Senate
what's it if you're not here goodbye and
now you're our cars our bets con again
good good it's very fast ya know what
down